okay so this is gonna be my relaxing day
like my day did I just do nothing I do
jack [ __ ] except watch bad TV and play
video games I'm a bad TV I mean sweet
TVs this Captain Marvel trailer came out
and I was like great don't feel like
doing a video about it so bring on the
TV or digital streaming services so well
I will admit this Captain Marvel
trailers better than the other ones we
got that's cool brie Larson even cracks
a couple jokes what is this announcing
your identity on clothing help with the
covert part of your job but that's the
problem and now this is on my mind how
does she have a shield hat doesn't this
take place in the 90s or something like
that like at least when blockbuster was
around it indeed is a shield logo like
not shield logo but a shield logo
wouldn't it be the logo of the strategic
homeland blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah is what it was called an Iron Man 1
until the very end of Iron Man 1 like in
the course of Iron Monger and all this
chaos they were like hey we found a name
officially but how if they already had
that name in Captain Marvel so either
this is a wreck on an oversight or Phil
Coulson was just [ __ ] with Tony Stark
the whole time okay check homeland
intervention right where's my logistics
division a new name for that yeah you're
just not cool enough for me to tell you
we've been calling it shield for decades
you got to earn that [ __ ] that's strange
I don't know why there's just kind of
plugging in my mind I guess I have
nothing better to they're like is this
the first MCU movie to do this like
Howard Stark was said to be a founding
member of shield we saw Hank Pym work
for shield and ant-man and that was
clearly way before ant-man 80s probably
but did they call it shield then that's
my question because they always
retrospectively call it shield but in
these scenes that take place in the past
was it ever called shield for the life
of me I can't remember because I've not
this is the first time it's happened
it's like a retcon that's a big right
con actually it's pretty trivial in the
grand scheme of things but what really
matters is when did they come up with
that name shield I was thinking the
other day they said Captain Marvel is
the most powerful of the Avengers right
that's a pretty high bar so in this
movie they have to actually show that
that's the case we can't have someone in
our world like producer say oh by the
way she's the strongest and not Shelley
and judging by the metric where the MCU
has set that bar best I can figure she
has to do something more powerful than
taking a dying star to the chest because
if she doesn't take a dying star to the
chest or something greater its Thor I'm
just saying it's Thor other than that I
enjoyed this trailer should have been
the first trailer so good in fact what I
wanted to talk about was when did they
come up with the name shield and props
to Samuel
for being smart in a situation like this
okay prove Vietnam scroll
[Music]
that's a photon blast and I was croaking
I'll do that I'm just supposed to take
your word for that right like that would
be stupid to take her word for it so
many movies are like boom the enemy
can't do that
alright you must be telling the truth
let's go on our adventure like it very
well it could be the enemy doing the
enemy thing saying the enemy who are the
bad guys what's that person actually is
couldn't do that thing that they just
did what a good bad guy would do so
props Nick fairy you're one of the smart
ones that questions that [ __ ] versus a
Captain Marvel trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it and diamond
stars in the chest and making good
points about how bad guys could lie
whatever you think come on below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more
[Music]